Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3 closes the
door for the title group in many ways as
what seems to be James Gunn's last ride
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe but the
movie's credit scenes definitely leave a
window open for more stories to come
warning spoilers for Guardians volume 3
ahead closure can be hard to find in a
Cinematic Universe that just keeps going
even when one character or group's story
ends there are still so many moving
components that those characters can
still pop up in other films the last
Iron Man movie came out in 2013 but Tony
Stark was still a key presence in the
MCU until his death in 2019's Avengers
end game and honestly even after
considering how much his Specter loomed
over Spider-Man far from home so it's
maybe a little surprising that while
Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3 isn't the
end of the MCU it actually does leave
the characters in interesting positions
where the audience can feel okay about
sending them off for the time B they
could always pop up elsewhere but the
movie does an excellent job of closing
out various character arcs by the time
the credits roll and as is custom in
Marvel movies there's a pair of
post-credits scenes that are worth
sticking around for if you want to feel
some extra big feelings before leaving
the theater
Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3 ends with
the crew going their separate ways
mantis looks to go find herself while
nebula and Drax plan to stay on nowhere
to rebuild and look after the kids they
rescued from the high evolutionary
however the Guardians will live on with
rocket as their new leader and he makes
for a fairly competent boss as audiences
can see in the mid-credit scene
Someday I'm gonna make great machines
that fly
and me and my friends are gonna go
flying together
rocket has brought his new Guardians
consisting of Adam Warlock his pet blurp
craglin Cosmo one of the rescue children
from the high evolutionary ship and an
even more roided out grouped on a new
planet they spend some much needed
bonding time going over their favorite
music the little girl is a fan of
Britney Spears and corn so she has very
tastes Cracklin has a soft spot for
Garth Brooks and Rocket's favorite is an
old throwback meant to put a smile on
long time fans faces rocket starts
playing come and get your love by
Redbone which viewers will instantly
recognize as the first song Peter Quill
plays as he's exploring a cave in the
opening of the first Guardians of the
Galaxy movie of course they don't have
time to enjoy it all as they're about to
be attacked by oncoming beasts so they
leap into action signifying how there
are still going to be Guardians
protecting those who were unable to
defend themselves the sequence shows the
Guardians of the Galaxy are more than
the core team from the first movie
they've evolved and if Marvel ever
decides to delve into those Waters again
volume 4 wouldn't be out of the question
so what about Star-Lord Peter hands off
leadership of the Guardians to Rocket
because he has other matters to attend
to for starters he wants to go back to
Earth to visit his still living
grandfather while Peter visited Earth
briefly during the fight against Thanos
he didn't exactly stick around Long
seemingly preferring his life as a space
Outlaw but over the course of the movie
he comes to understand how important it
would be to see his grandfather again
after so many decades especially
considering he lost his daughter and
Grandson on the same day
the movie ends with Peter meeting up
with his granddad and the post-credits
scene provides a glimpse into a day in
the life of the newly reunited family
there's nothing of real consequence to
the scene and that's the point they sit
down at the table eating breakfast
talking about something inconsequential
while Peter's Grandpa reads the
newspaper which coincidentally has a
headline about Kevin Bacon getting
abducted by aliens
it's Kevin Bacon he's not a loser he's
great we don't hate him at all it's a
moment of peace and Tranquility after
Decades of struggling to survive in
space however Peter's days as a hero
likely aren't over yet a title card
follows the scene that reads the
legendary Star-Lord will return it
remains to be seen if that'll be in a
Solo installment a reuniting of the
Guardians or a team-up project like
Avengers Secret Wars but at least Peter
got to spend a bit of time with his
grandfather before the next adventure
[Music]